uh for the first uh talk of this uh
afternoon session we it's a pleasure to
introduce uh sohail faizi from uh
uh university of maryland take it away
thank you so much thanks uh for the
invitation thanks everyone for being
here so today i'm going to talk about
studying failure modes of deep learning
and potential ways to fix them
okay we have all witnessed recent
success of deep learning in many areas
ranging from self-driving cars and
vision to robotics to national language
processing games reinforcement learning
you name it
the question we are asking in this
presentation is in fact whether
deep learning models in practice are
reliable
in order to study this question first we
need to say how we can measure
reliability so i'm going to briefly
spend some time to explain the second
question and then we are going to talk
about the first
of course one standard measure of
reliability is accuracy and there have
been a lot of work in the last decade to
increase accuracy of models on benchmark
datasets like imagenet by either coming
up with better architectures or
better training approaches in order to
basically improve the accuracy on on
these benchmarks but obviously just
accuracy alone is not sufficient and we
need to look into some other aspects of
these models such as distributional
robustness
let me explain that with a simple
example
here if you take some pre-trained models
on imagenet and you evaluate those
models on a slightly different data set
of object net so basically the the
status that has the same
labels but objects may have like
different orientations or backgrounds
and if you do that you see a significant
drop in the performance by like 40 45
percentage points meaning that these
models are in fact not very robust these
types of distributional shifts in the
data set
so another issue is uh adversarial
robustness of these models
here we are adding some small but
potentially imperceptible noise to the
input in order to
fool the model and have an incorrect
classification
here for example your inkling input is
egyptian cat for both model and humans
and we are adding a small noise for
humans still this image is a cat but for
model
the prediction is a traffic light so
that's why we are saying this example is
an adversarial example for them
and we have observed that even in the
presence of very small adversarial
perturbation the performance of these
models can drop quite significantly from
80 to basically almost zero
obviously we need to consider other
aspects like test time interpretability
training time interpretability fairness
and basically using such a such an
evaluation simplex we can evaluate
models
using a radar chart to have a more
complete picture of their performance
that we'll see in practice
over the last years we have studied
different aspects of reliability in the
first part of the talk i'm going to
mainly focus on adversarial robustness
which is the theme of this workshop and
i'm going to present some of the recent
results in this domain
in the second part of the talk i'm going
to step back and ask this question if
there is a common reason a root cause
behind many of these reliability issues
in deep learning in a way if you could
identify it resolve it and deal with it
we can increase reliability of models
across the board so that's going to be
the focus of the second part of the talk
and by the way feel free to interrupt me
if you have any questions
okay so let's get started adversarial uh
robustness problem so in the adversarial
attack problem
the goal is to create an adversarial
example x prime by maximizing a
classification laws to mislead the model
f
and this x prime should belong to a
certain set we call that said a threat
model
probably the most standard threat models
are lp
threat models where the lp distance
between x and x prime are bonded within
a certain threshold rule
and of course
robustness against lp is very important
to understand but by no means it is
sufficient because there are many non-lp
attacks that won't fall into the lp
threat models and they can break the
system they can break hormones
these non-np attacks include like
attacks like special attacks you
especially uh change your objects or
some semantic level attacks you recolor
your image in order to create
adversarial examples and many many other
examples
okay so we are going to mainly focus in
this talk on provable or certifiable
defenses
what i mean by that we say a classifier
f is certifiably robust at a particular
point x
if for all points in a certain radius of
that point
let's say with the radius row
the output of the classifier remains the
same
right here in this example you have x
with the green label and for all points
in a radius row of the x the label
remains the same and that's what we are
saying row is the certification level or
robustness level
okay in the last
five years i i should say there have
been a lot of interesting ideas to come
up with such provable and certifiable
methods against adversarial
perturbations so first i'm going to
categorize them based on the amount of
the network information they used in the
defense again the attack is white box
attack can use any information
it wants from the network but i'm going
to classify the defenses based on the
amount of the network information they
use in the defense
so focusing on lp
threat models in one extreme we have
defenses based on randomize the small
thing
so basically these methods they only
look at input output relationship
without looking into the underlying
mechanics of the net fork and these
methods because of that they are very
scalable to deep models and high
resolution data sets like imagenet
in the other extreme we have methods
that basically bound the curvature or
lipschitz values of the network and
because of that it basically bounced the
variations of the output with respect to
the input and uh come up with provable
robustness but these methods are
successful on shallow networks but not
yet they are not scalable to deep and
practical modes
as i mentioned non-lp attacks are also
important
uh we can think about provable
robustness against non-lp attacks for
example in sparse attacks
adversary can change few pixels in the
image in order to craft an adversarial
example
in washington threat model
you normalize an image to view that as a
distribution and then bound the
washerstein distance in order to
basically
have a model for special variations in
the adversarial examples and in patch
threat basically adversary puts an
adversarial patch in order to mislead
the model so you can think about
provable defenses against these types of
non-lp
attacks as well
so in the first part of the talk i'm
going to mainly focus on randomized
smoothing because as i mentioned
randomized smoothing is probably like
the most practical
certifiable and provable defense that we
can use on deep models and high
resolution data sets like image
okay so let me first review the basics
of randomized smoothing starting with
this paper by cohen and co-authors
so a smooth classifier is defined as
following so you
yes
yes of course on the introduction so the
idea of
you know uh
idiot robustness here is related to
having better classifiers in the sense
that they perform better out of sample
or easy the goal to have classifiers
that are robust to malicious attempts to
sort of trick them and are these two
things different
uh they are different uh so in the first
part then we are talking about
distributional robustness which i'll
talk a little bit later on during the
talk
is that you have some natural variations
in your inputs so these are not
malicious changes that you are imposing
to your input for example you have an
image of a chair
and you classify it you know correctly
on imagenet but you go to another data
set and maybe the background is a little
bit different or the chair orientation
is different and so these are natural
changes and we want models to be robust
to these types of natural changes
in the adversarial robustness that i'm
basically the focus of the first part is
that we intentionally impose some
perturbations to the input in order to
make sure the model auto doesn't change
and these inputs can be very small
but these perturbations they can
potentially be a function of the model
itself
uh in terms of like attack optimization
they are not like just random uh no
noise that they are adding to the input
does that make sense
yes so just a small question on on the
first part so the idea is um
um say
uh
it's okay
later if i don't okay
any other questions
okay so in
smoothing so we have a base classifier f
this f can be anything it can be a
neural network it can be even a linear
function it can be image so we add some
noise to this input and we look at the
expectation of this function as the
smooth function that's what we call a
smooth classifier f bar
and this epsilon noise it can have
different distributions for example in
gaussian smoothing this epsilon is
according to a gaussian density function
the intuition behind the smoothing is
that your base classifier may have some
sharp decision boundaries and it creates
some adversarial sensitivity for example
here if you have an input x here with
the small perturbation you can go from
the green region to the blue region but
if you do a smoothing you're basically
smoothing out some of these sharp
decision boundaries and potentially you
increase the intrinsic robustness of
your mod
how does the
robustness guarantees work here
it is basically uh not hard to show that
a smooth classifier can be shown to be
provably lipschitz i'm going to show one
such example and when you have provable
lipsciousness then robustness comes for
free because you have a bound on the
variations of the outputs with respect
to name
okay so that's basically a very quick
overview of uh small thing
in our
icml paper we studied the additive
smoothing
some issues of additive smoothing why
i'm saying it is additive because you're
just adding noise to the input right so
you you generate some noise from
gaussian or any other distribution
you're adding to the input so that's
additive smoothing
so we identified some issues in additive
smoothing the first one is the curse of
dimensionality we showed that there is
an upper bound on the robustness
guarantees that any additive smoothing
can achieve and this bond is something
like this that depends on sigma which is
the
standard deviation of the noise d is the
dimension p1 and p2 they are the
probabilities of the top class and the
runner-up class
but if you think about this bond the
scaling is not good because with higher
in higher dimensions especially when p
is larger than two you have some extra
dependence on the dimension and this
bond quickly goes to zero
yes
fantastic question so let me repeat the
question and then i'll answer them so
here basically this is an upper bound
for any lp attack p doesn't have to be
true
right so the sigma is an element wise
variance of your noise right so the
magnitude of the noise is basically
sigma square root of t but this radius
is the radius of the perturbation of the
image so you have one scaling of square
root of d there
but when p is larger than two you have
an additional dependence
does that make sense
so this is a negative result basically
you cannot have any smoothing additive
smoothing that can beat this bound and
this bond is not good
so p1x is the uh basically the top the
probability of top class for that
particular sample is the top logic and
p2 is p2x is the the runner-up class
what is the second best class for that
particular image in the given moment
this is the upper bound on the
robustness radius against empty attack
maybe like but of course changing x to
something else will change
f
bar
do you impose something
yes but within this lp attack let's say
you have an empty ball of radius
row star of p so you you cannot have a
larger radius than this in order to
repeat the same label within that ball
oh you
but
there are some logics
you just want the top label to stay the
same yes because otherwise you know you
will have a specification you don't look
at that
exactly
yes uh so do you assume what kind of
data distribution do you assume to get
your this is general so this is general
for any data distribution and not only
that this is
true for any additive distribution for
this small thing it doesn't have to be
gaussian
but maybe you need to be more specific
what if you had five dimensional data
it's like dimension d but on the low
dimensional matrix
you still get that dependence on yes
it is the same thing
okay uh the other problem which is more
obvious what can be critical in some
application is that we get probabilistic
certificates not deterministic ones
because you can never compute this
expectation exactly so we always have
some bounce upper and lower bounds with
high probability we can do the
certification
you can say maybe 99 probability is good
but in some application that may not be
good because you won't like to be
be able to guarantee with hundred
percent certain
so we ask easily because of the
additivity nature of smoothing can be
come up with some non-additive
smoothing
distributions in order to
improve the certificates in in some of
these aspects
and that's basically the focus of or uh
other icml paper with my student alex
levin so here we introduce a method
called non-additive smoothing with
splitting noise
in short ssm
that will uh basically lead to some
improve
improve properties of the
robustness
so first let me explain the noise
distribution with some
examples suppose you have a pixel value
between zero and one
before i'm just adding a gaussian noise
to this x right so that's why i'm saying
it is additive so i want to add some do
some non-additive smoothing on this so
what i'm going to do is that i'm going
to first generate a splitting variable
uniformly between 0 and 2 lambda
so that's my splitting value
and then depending on which interval
this x i falls i'm going to map it to
the center of that interval
basically i'm adding some quantization
noise to x where the quantization level
is drawn uniformly
randomly from an interval between zero
and two lambda
very simple
no is that your app
okay but this
simple noise it has
some amazing properties some of them
actually we didn't intend at the
beginning and then i'm going to explain
what properties we get
so first of all
we get robustness for free
if you have if you smooth using this
distribution
with this non-additive splitting noise
the smooth classifier is guaranteed to
be one over two lambda ellipses with
respect to the l1 node
and therefore you get provable
robustness against l1 attacks
so i'm going to show a simple proof of
this and also show some generalization
for other elements
but probably more important than this
result is this following property
splitting variables do not need to be
independent therefore smoothing can be
done effectively in one dimension and
can be randomized
so what do i mean by that so suppose we
have a two-dimensional problem for
simplicity let's say we have a discrete
problem like image pixel values
so you have two splitting variables s1
and s2 in order to add quantization
noise splitting noise to your of your
pixels
so in order to have a deterministic
function as your smoothing you need to
evaluate the output of the function in
each of these realizations of these
splitting variables
but this can be very very expensive
especially in high dimensional problems
if we don't need the splitting variables
to be independent i can pick any joint
distribution as long as the marginal
distributions are uniform for example i
can pick this distribution
as long as because the marginals is
uniform and just count the number of
points that you get it is basically the
same number of points that you get in
one of the rows
so it may not seem like a big deal from
two dimension to one dimension but think
about images
in imagenet with hundred thousands of
dimensions and effectively we reduce the
smoothing to be done in one dimension
and also provide the ten minutes the
guarantees for us
so where this comes from right so that
is the main property that we have here
what is the intuition behind ssn again
for simplicity let's focus on a two
dimensional problem suppose you have two
inputs x and x prime
and you want to add splitting noise to
them basically first you generate
splitting variables randomly s1 and s2
for each of the dimensions and you map
x's to the
basically the center of these quadrants
that they fall into
here you don't have any collision so x
and x prime are mapped to the different
points because they are not in the same
quadrant
but with some chance because we are
drawing these splitting variables
randomly with some chance they may
happen to be in the same platform and
therefore they're going to be mapped to
the same point
so here you have collision
with some probability you have collision
now let's look at the difference between
the output of the smooth function at x
and x prime it is very easy to show that
this is bounded by the probability that
their smooth version do not collide
because if they collide you get the same
value
if they don't collide and the functions
are bounded the range is between 0 and 1
you get this probability it is very easy
to show that
so what is this probability
the probability that they don't collide
their smooth version is the same as the
probability that at least one of their
dimensions don't collide because if one
of the dimensions don't collide they
don't collide
okay so how can i compute this
probability
i use union bound
basically this probability is the
probability that my splitting
variable happens to cut the
distance that the interval
the between the eighth coordinate of x
and x prime and that probability is
nothing but the difference in the y
coordinate which is delta i over 2
lambda because the splitting variable is
uniform from 0 to 2 left
and what you get here you get l 1 norm
of delta which is the distance between x
and x prime over 2 lambda
immediately this shows it is lip sheets
in maybe two lines
therefore you guarantee you can
guarantee against perturbations but more
importantly
did i use anywhere the independence of
these splitting variables
no i didn't because i use union bond
therefore i don't have constraints on
the joint distributions of these
splitting values except the marginal
should be uniform that's easy too that's
how does this work in practice
it basically works really well it is the
state of the art
uh in terms of provable robustness even
in the imagenet scale the red one is the
previous state of the art that use
uniform noise
and the blue one is the basically
curve that we get y axis is the
certified radius we basically double the
certified robustness but not only that
we also get better clean accuracy
compared to the previous state of the
earth basically we get the best of the
two volts
so recently we have extended this to
other lp threat models especially
fractional lp3 models
what we do we consider a general a more
general threat model with this distance
so what is this distance between x and x
tilde i can apply any concave function
to the difference between the i
coordinate of x and x still t
and this concave function
should be from zero to one to zero to
one at origin it should be zero
for example if this is identity you get
l one
but you can get other fractional lp
by just picking this function as in this
form for example you can think about
like
p is equal to half or one third
i would expect to choose
convex
you know i mean yes the distances are
convex
functional it doesn't work for convex
okay so that's why we need like
fractional of we are basically looking
at fractional p
so it's a long story why it doesn't work
for lp i'm happy to talk about it
offline uh but the
basically for the
for the concave bonds we show that you
can extend the splitting noise through
something called valuable gamma same
thing that i'm not gonna talk because it
is fairly technical
and you can get provable robustness um
we are going to present it in areas this
year but uh that's a great question um
uh we think that actually there are some
negative results for for the convex case
i'm happy to chat about that often
okay so let me pause it if there see
there are any questions
something i guess we um
i guess there's a trade-off here and i
guess from your theory one side of the
trade-off is clear but the other is not
present which is i can definitely make
something super smooth by just having
one cell
and pointing all the images in the
center of the cell
so
um
yeah i guess i didn't see like i mean
you know like it's only experimental
evidence i guess that you do better with
this approach but a priori
presumably you weren't sure if this is
going to work or not i wonder what was
the process
that's a great question so um as kostas
mentioned there's always a let me just
repeat so there's always a trade-off
between certified or robustness
certified accuracy versus clean accuracy
right because if you you know smooth in
the extreme and map everything to one
point then you have amazing robustness
but not so useful model
of course we
look at different parameters sigma is
the parameter that we have
and
we not only get increased robustness we
also get increased clean accuracy
compared to the previous state of the
art and this was a little bit surprising
at the beginning but there is actually a
reason behind that
because previous methods they are just
uniform noise additive uniform noise to
the input
and there is a range of the
unif the values that the pixel value
doesn't carry any information because
any value could be generated because of
the magnitude of the uniforms
but in our case because we are adding
some structured noise it is much easier
for the network to learn that basically
value is probably some
a value with without any information and
because of the model learns faster and
has
a
bit better clean accuracy but of course
we don't have theory on that so it is
just empirical um evaluation and some
hypothesis that we have
yes
because i thought the philosophy of the
exercise was to make them better out of
samples so the family chairs that you
saw at the
beginning so
this part is about adversarial
robustness right so um in the second
part i'm going to talk a little bit
about distribution
so sorry from the last comment you made
i guess it was implied that uh it's not
this you train some model and then do
your smoothing but like then you go back
like there's a
you train the model
anticipating you're gonna do smoothing
on the model that you trained yeah so
there are some ways even in the
first gaussian smoothing
uh usually like first of all you inject
noise during training otherwise the
numbers are not good or you can do like
some other you know days like doing
adversarial training and stuff
so we do we repeat all of those
techniques but of course there is this
hyper parameter which basically we have
lambda here that shows like the
magnitude of the noise you're adding uh
we evaluate it for a range of it and
that's why we have like you know a trade
of curve between between robustness and
the clean accuracy
make sense
yes
post process situation
right now
no
deterministic
smoothing with the splitting noise
just because you follow the
non-independent case you call it like
that yeah because
the thing is that like here we don't
need independence so i can evaluate
all of the possible outputs for my noise
because i basically i effectively do
smoothing in one dimension that's why we
have determinism here so not only
another i have to say another
property compared to the previous state
of the art is that we are deterministic
so we say it is with hundred percent we
guarantee robust
okay so for the interest of time oh god
now i have some tough decisions to make
okay
all right so we have basically improved
robustness better clean accuracy
it is time to celebrate
or is it
oh okay so let's go back to the picture
that we started with uh basically we
started with this uh landscape of
provable defenses but there is a hidden
assumption here
and that hidden assumption is basically
here that
we assume the defense knows the threat
model used by the attack
in 99.9 of adversarial robustness work
in the literature this is the assumption
and this is probably like the most
unrealistic assumption that you can
think about because by definition
adversity is not a nice person you can
ask that verse oh my defense is for l2
like you know please don't use like
other threat models right so practically
you know we need to understand
generalization of robustness
so when what happens if the defense
doesn't know which threat model attack
is going to be based on
so uh this part uh
we start with the thought experiment
maybe there's no issue here we take a
data set like c410 we take an
adversarial training approach which has
been covered in the workshop it's a min
max problem in the max you find worse
perturbations within a threat model and
in the mean part you train your model
for those perturb samples
let's say we do a infinity adversarial
training
robot's accuracy against l infinity we
get roughly speaking 50 percent there
are some works improve this number by a
couple of percentage points
50 percent not too bad we are still
working to make it better
but now if you look at robust accuracy
against l2
you get
20 percent
and think about this this is c4 10 is
random random guessing you get 10
percent but with all of the you know the
the the hypes that we have for l2 we get
basically 20
and this is not just for uh for this
particular defense so we have observed
similar behavior across many many other
defenses
uh it's a joint work with two of my
students cassidy uh late law and saheed
singh
the same radius uh roughly speaking the
same because they're the metrics are
different
uh so how to translate one to another
i'll talk about it but both of them are
imperceptible
so basically what we say here is
standard defenses they have poor
generalization to enforce in adversarial
attacks
so the question is how can we develop a
defense with improved
generalizability to enforce internet
models when you don't know the threat
model ahead of time
okay as i mentioned this is a joint fork
with my
students
okay in order to understand this
question we need to understand the
relationship between the threat models
think about this big box as the set of
all unconstrained adversarial examples
for an input and think about this blue
set as the set of imperceptible
adversarial examples these are the
perturbations that humans can't tell the
difference from between x and x prime
the issue is that we don't have a good
mathematical characterization of this
set
therefore what we do we try to fill this
up using narrow thread models like lp
spatial threat model patch threat model
but the issue is that even if you have a
model that is robust against union of
these threat models you have many many
adversarial examples that do not fall in
the union therefore your model can
potentially be very vulnerable against
those adversarial examples
so instead of this bottom-up approach we
propose a new view to this problem a
top-down view
that we directly approximate this set of
imperceptible adversarial examples using
a neural network
basically we look at all x prime such
that the neural perceptual distance
between x and x prime is within a
certain threshold we call it neural
perceptual thread mode
okay so what distance we use for the
neural perceptual uh
as our neural perceptual distance we use
lpips learn perceptual image patch
similarity but our framework is general
other
distances can also be used so what is
lpips
so you take a
perceptual network g and you have an
input x
and you push your x to this network
and then you look at the normalized
activations of different layers as a
feature extractor for x so these are
basically perceptual quote unquote
perceptual features for x
now if you have another x tilde another
image you can do the same thing you can
extract phi of x tilde
and if you look at the l2 distance
between 5 of x and 5x still that's
basically the lpips distance or the
neural perceptual distance that we use
if for two images this is less than a
threshold
but
when you push these images to your model
and you get different labels we call
this x tilde a perceptual adversarial
example for your mod
but of course the question here is how
you can pick
these uh perceptual networks in order to
compute these pi of x's
so you can have different choices one is
you take a pre-trained model like
alexnet
and use that as your perceptual uh
network or
more interestingly you can use the same
network for perceptual feature
extraction and for the classification
and if you do that basically during
adversarial training your threat model
is changing it is adaptive because your
model is changing
okay so let's look at the attack problem
in the l2 attack we solve this
optimization
obviously we do the first order
approximation at the beginning replacing
the objective it is first order
approximation and the constraint is
convex so we can solve this exactly and
the solution is basically follow the
gradient and project if you are outside
of the ball of feasibility
in the perceptual attack we have the
same objective but no or constrain is
that the phi of x minus five of x prime
uh in the
two distances less than rule
we do the same practice we look at the
first order approximation of the two
we have this convex optimization problem
we can solve it exactly
and now we have this term that depends
on the jacobian of the phi with respect
to the input
this is the optimal direction that we
should move so what is the intuition
here
gradient tells me which direction i
should go to maximally increase my loss
the other term tells me there are some
directions that i can go further but i
don't change perceptibility of my image
so i can add larger magnitude noise
without being perceptible and this
formula basically combines the two so we
want to increase the loss but not being
too perceptible
so when we apply this attack the attack
is basically really strong uh in fact if
you have any defense you should uh try
against the perceptual attack because my
knowledge that's the strongest uh
adversarial attack we have you can see
even this is the original image this is
the adversarial
one and here the lighting is changed
slightly to create an adversarial
example here the background is changed
the edges are changed or the texture of
this uh snow
man is changed in order to create
adversarial examples and i want to
emphasize
we haven't integrated this constraint in
our optimization these will come
naturally because of the perceptual
constraint that we have in our attack
problem
okay so i started this part by claiming
that we have a good approximation of the
set of imperceptible adversarial example
but how can we verify that so we do a
mechanical torque study
so what we do is we show pairs of
examples clean and adversarial to
users and ask to see if they can notice
the change or not
if the change is imperceptible
then probably they won't be able to tell
the difference if the change is
perceptible they can't tell the
difference
so with attacks generated by different
threat models we basically in the y-axis
have the human perceptibility
uh of their perturbations versus the
x-axis which is the neural perceptual
distance
and you can see the correlation here it
is like amazing it is above 80 85
percent correlation
meaning that i ca i could just look at
the neural perceptual distance and tell
if the users are going to be able to
tell the difference between the x and x
prime or not
in other words in fact this
approximation is good and we have a good
correlation between the perceptibility
and the moral perceptions
we tried this on imagenet and uh for the
sake of time i'm not gonna go into the
details of this table
but uh here the rules are adversarially
adversarial training
based on different threat models like l
infinity l2
maybe all of them and pat means
adversarial training against perceptual
threat model that we introduce
self here means we have the same
perceptual and classification network
and alexnet means we have we use alexnet
for for the perceptual network and as
you can see the numbers that we get for
the union of the attacks or uh
robustness against unseen attacks are
significantly higher than the previous
methods
this basically shows uh this method has
a good generalization against unseen
attacks
okay
time to celebrate this time uh probably
for real
but there are several challenges remain
uh so so far i have discussed robustness
in the static setup so you have an image
classifier it is static what happens in
adaptive learning like reinforcement
learning so this is a much more
difficult problem because
an adversary can see the defense you
applied in the previous times therefore
adversity can adapt it is a strategy
so we have a recent paper uh it is going
to appear in iclr this year that we have
a provable defense against such cases
let me finish this part so you you can
also look at robustness in other
complex prediction tests for example in
detection
that your output is not a single label
or robustness of beyond labels like
interpretation or fairness or other
measures
okay so there was a question i mean in
the case of classifier and
classifying an emails
or not i understand the question in
reinforcement what is the task that
we're trying to protect
well the task is the following so you
have an agent
okay uh and adversely i can say okay
adversary can prepare the observation of
the agent within the two balls
right an adversary can
basically use all of the perturbation in
one time or it can spread it over times
and the goal is to make sure that the
reward is
uh bounded so you have a defense that
adversely cannot lower the reward below
a certain threshold
and then you say that can be in every
uh
in every point
it was up to the adversary and that is
the adaptive nature of that
that makes the problem extremely
difficult so
i'm happy to chat about it often
okay uh so that concludes the first part
of the talk on adversarial robustness
okay so
[Music]
so the second part is basically we want
to
understand potential good cause of these
issues
so we start with some thought
experiments
for a subset of imagenet samples we
collected segmentation masks for the
entire object
to test sensitivity of the models to
backgrounds versus foregrounds and we
observe some really strange behaviors
for example we take a robust resonant 50
model it has a very good clean accuracy
now we add noise to the background in
this case and noise to the foreground in
the other case
right so you expect that when you add
noise to the main object your model
performance should drop quite
significantly
and not so to the background
but we basically observe the opposite
behavior so when you noise out the main
object
the probability of frog increases
versus when you noise out the background
the probability of the frog decreases
which is the which should be the other
way around and it is not like a one-time
thing even on other models
seem clear we observe the same thing and
these are the pictures that i had in my
opening slide so you add noise to the
deer
you expect the model should the
performance should drop it increases
and you add noise to the background and
you expect the performance of the model
shouldn't change but it decreases quite
significantly
so
basically we studied first the
um four
yes
can you can you uh pause uh because
yeah yeah i'll find i need to like uh
go to some messages i have so basically
we studied the robustness under
foreground and infinity noise and under
background l infinity noise in a plot
like this
so y axis shows general robustness if
your model is here it means it is
generally more robust this access shows
model uses more foreground core features
compared to background features okay so
we evaluated several models some of the
messages that we have transformers they
have high general robustness
that is somehow expected
but we also have like some unexpected
behaviors this little uh red triangle is
the robust resonant and this green one
is the uh clean resonant and we see that
robust resonant actually has lower
relative robustness compared to clean
resonance it means that it uses
background
more than the foreground compared to the
regular resonance
which is somehow counterintuitive
because you think about robustness
the robustness should the robust model
should somehow use more core and the
foreground features this is exactly the
opposite
way we have some hypothesis why this is
the case but this is an unintended
consequence of adversarial training
and this is not just because of the
hyper parameter we tried different hyper
parameters even different resonant
structures the same thing happens it is
not a cherry picked extreme experiment
okay uh
so i'll skip this slide for the sake of
time
to study reliance of models on
experience features we need large-scale
data sets with rich feature annotations
but we have a lot of challenges here the
manual feature annotation is very
expensive you cannot go one by one and
annotate your images
and you may actually miss some relevant
features
and there are some experience features
that are not background look at this
example you have a class of desk and
there is a computer here this computer
is a spurious feature for this test but
it is on the foreground not the
background so it is hard to basically
crop these types of images
and also we need
to identify experience features using
general models can we do that the answer
is yes
so we have proposed a methodology
that will appear in iclr this year so
instead of annotating
individual images the idea is to
annotate neural features directly using
maybe a handful of examples
let me be more concrete
we take a robust resnet 50 model we look
at the penultimate layer neurons
for each neuron i identify maybe three
five
images that highly activate this neuron
three or five
and i visualize this neuron for these
images
and i show it to my amt workers and i
ask them if this neuron that is
visualized on these images is it core or
experience does it highlight core email
parts of the image or experience
that's it so with three or five images
we annotate these neurons as core or
spheres and then i can automatically use
these annotations to annotate the entire
training and test set that i have
uh in terms of their core and serious
features
so how do we visualize these neural
features
we either use heat maps that highlight
the important parts of the image for
example here this neuron highlights the
mountain but sometimes this can be a
little bit tricky
does it highlight the fence or the tiger
here it is not clear right because
we have an ambiguity here
in these cases we use a method called
feature attack that visually amplifies
these features on the image
so here mountain has been amplified so
then it is clear the neuron is actually
looking at the mountain but here fence
has been amplified therefore this neuron
is actually looking at the fence not the
tiger so it helps the users to to do the
annotation
so using this approach now we present a
data set called salient imagenet
so
it has samples in this form so it has x
and y like imagenet but it has two masks
one is the core mask
highlighting core parts of the image and
the other one is the experience mask
highlighting experience features in the
image
and we provide this for almost the
entire imagenet dataset because of this
scalable method that we have more than a
million samples all classes
and this shows the number of images uh
with at least three spurious features
and some classes like seatbelt the top
five features that we have all of them
are experienced so these are extremely
difficult
difficult classes
so using this we can repeat the noise
analysis you can add noise to the core
features
and look at the model performance that
is the spurious accuracy
because you're noising out the core
features you expect a high drop in the
performance
or you can add noise to the experience
features and look at the drop in the
performance and again you expect a low
drop in the performance
we look at the for example a standard
resonant 50 model a particular drake
class
here we are adding noise to the core
features
we expect a high drop in the performance
we get zero percent drop
here we are adding noise to the
experience for which is the water we
expect a
small drop in the performance
we get 41 percent drop in the
performance
this is for me it was mind-blowing when
i saw these results first basically it
should be the other way
so i'll skip the rest so we
evaluated 42 models uh we have basically
shown some
interesting behaviors for example
there was a discussions on clip vits
that are very
modern models but if you look at their
numbers they basically mostly use the
background information
so these are some of the analysis that
can be very useful to go beyond
accuracy
so we started with this data formulation
that we have only label for xs and the
data comes from iid
and for that we formulate the learning
as an empirical risk minimization
problem
but now we see that this doesn't work
because the models they mainly use
experience features they are not robust
they are not interpretable so my
suggestion is to go back to the drawing
board and rethink about data formulation
maybe use richly annotated and diverse
statuses like we have in the in the
causal the salient image that we have
core and experience mass and that will
potentially open up about thinking about
new learning procedures for
for those data sets
so i'm not going to talk about it we
have some recent attempt we have a core
risk minimization that we add noise to
the input and we train a model that is
insensitive to basically noise to
non-core regions
and with that we have
really improved results but it is still
an open problem and if you're thinking
about some problems
that can be a good problem to work on
so let me
wrap it up so in the first part i talked
about
adversarial robustness provable
robustness uh we introduced a
non-adjective smoothing with splitting
noise
in the second part of that we talked
about robustness generalization using
neural perceptual threat models and in
the second part of the talk we talked
about reliance of the models on
experience features
we have two richly annotated data set
rival 10 is smaller
is manually annotated and salient imager
is basically automatically annotated
almost all of the image net
so we are going to have some data
releases of these uh
data sets pretty soon so if you're
interested
please
contact me so i'll be happy to
discuss some ideas we have
and
that's it so thank you everyone
[Applause]
any questions uh thank you sahel
any questions first i have
yes
thanks so much really interesting stuff
um could you talk a little bit more
about like the um um where you're using
like the siamese networks like do the
perceptual um networks or sorry to learn
like perceptual um like adversarial
examples yes uh you're not doing like a
metric learning with the siamese
networks right or could you talk a
little bit more about that i think i got
lost a little bit yeah so basically in
the
perceptual one so you
use a perceptual network to extract
these features right but who gives you
this network so one thing is that you
can use a pre-trained network like
alexnet and use that as your feature
extractor and use that as defining your
threat model that's easy but you can say
okay maybe i'm going to use my own
classification network for the feature
extraction but if you do that
when you're doing adversarial training
your model changes therefore your threat
model changes
right so that's basically there's the
second point that i mentioned in fact
with the second one we have an improved
uh generalization number compared to the
first one
does that answer your question yeah so
you're not like training the model
specifically to learn the perception
like the
so i perception a related question so um
the second part of your talk made the
point that uh many of these networks at
least look at the wrong places for
labels yes
at the same time i thought your
perceptual distance kind of like relies
on features extracted by something like
alexnet
for what are
[Music]
imperceptible
uh perturbations like
you know like if alexander is speaking
the wrong features why i mean yes yeah
great point so uh
in the first part we talk about
very very small changes like these are
not like changes that
basically have some meaningful
uh
natural changes in the image so that's
why alex and the features that we
extract they seem to be meaningful in
that regime but in the second part we
are talking about some
high level
features that can potentially be removed
or be added
compared to
between the training and the test time
so these are like bigger changes
that you have in your data
and you may say that okay so maybe this
feature looks at the border right so
this is like a bigger region
uh and it is okay because as humans we
also look at the context and we look at
the
we look at the background but the issue
is that when in the test time
you have a different object with the
same context so these are bigger changes
that you have and in those cases the
model makes a mistake or maybe the more
interesting example is this you have a
bird
and there's a branch a model looks at
the branch
to
basically predict it's a bird but in the
test time
you have a branch but then you have a
frog on the branch
a model because it looks at the branch
it says it's a birth
right so these are the basically larger
changes that you have between your two
distributions in the first part we are
looking at imperceptible changes like
very small
adversarial changes that you have and
maybe because of that
the features are
more meaningful
yes
so i have two questions one um
so how does this
did you look at any of the results on
the outward distribution how would they
how would how would it change the
performance of the models if you
uh if you train with not experienced
speech basically you don't learn the
spurious features
and the second question is how much of
this is translatable to nlp
stuff because you mentioned that the
transformers are actually really good
fantastic two questions
both of them are great so in terms of
like evaluating on od distributions
or distributions without like these
experience features
so we are starting to
look into some of those problems right
so we spend a lot of time in the second
part just to
got these to get these annotations not
only useful for us but hopefully useful
for the community but to double check
their high quality and stuff but now we
have those annotations and richly
annotated data set can we think about
learning right uh so far we are just
looking at
accuracy measures like core and spurious
when or out of distributions basically
we are noising out
some of the core or
spurious ones and see how model uh
performs
and if we do some uh treatments like
core risk minimization we can see okay
your clean accuracy roughly remains the
same your core accuracy increases by 11
but your experience accuracy drops by
three percent so that is good so the
next step we also want to look at
the performance when you change your
data set and you get like some natural
uh variations in your experience feature
distributions or core feature
distributions we haven't done that yet
hopefully you think that with such
approaches you'll get a good
generalization
and for the second question um i believe
very similar approach with the same
framework can be used for nlp tasks
uh the idea again is to not to annotate
individual sentences or inputs but
annotate
neural features and
maybe with some uh methods like some
models like you know birth or some other
things you can do that annotation and
then highlight the parts of the sentence
that are core or experience for a
particular prediction
when you have that annotation then you
can ask all of these questions and train
better and hopefully improve moments
make sense
so let's take further questions at the
break thank you very much sahil thanks
everyone
and see you in 15 for good hairstock